hello guys how are you guys all doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
and today we are here with episode
number 6 obviously its height the [__]
look at my mini-map you already know
it's about to go down so today we are
here with as I said episode number 6 but
before we get into it we're gonna take a
look at the cashback that currently have
I have six point two six two mill just
add it onto here puts us at sixteen
point seven pretty much so that's what
we're gonna be starting off this episode
with we're gonna start with some heavy
ballista flips as you can see right now
there's like mmm ATK margins on them so
if I can buy my limit then I should be
able to make a pretty decent amount of
profit so that's what we're gonna start
off with
well the needless say I guess but
nonetheless the heavy ballista merch did
not really go well after I bought and
sold one and got my money back it just
stopped buying so that's where we are
with that hope these treasonous rings
really good margin on them if these do
indeed sell we will be making a pretty
nice amount of money to drop the price
just a little bit 10k sold them for
twelve point eight seven three as you
can see though our coins are now at one
or sixteen point nine five mill sided to
do some more seed merges as you can see
I've bought 93 torsional seeds for that
tour still see it sell for 41 K and 50g
piece we're gonna throw in four there
and then snapdragons we have 133 but we
go back you can see that they sell for
44 nine or eight nine eight however the
guide price is a lot higher than that so
I'm just gonna try to throw them in for
the guy price around fifty five five
hundred holy [__] I didn't even notice
this whenever I put it in this instance
sold huh okay well we're gonna we're
gonna change the price up on that a
little bit got back from playing nope
not playing got back from soccer and all
the snapdragons have sold however no
more have bought of either of the seeds
I'm gonna check out the torsional seed
price by one sell the rest and then
we'll find new items so with this one I
am going to give a shout out to someone
that commented on one of my other videos
Royal Jamaal
thanks for the merch man anyways he told
me that there was a mill margin on
gilded plate legs and I didn't believe
him I was like he probably [__] up or
something I thought he was like gonna
ask for money because he tried to
merchant and he [__] up or something
but nonetheless look at this [__] I was
asking if he had done these so I could
know if I could do them however he just
didn't say anything look at this bought
two for two mil pretty much sold them on
for 2.9 each that's a 1.8 milk profit
there's no way I'm up to 15 mil 15.1 and
I have another 3.8 ready to count like
this we're about to be up to 19 mil
barely into this video
well these seeds actually took a lot
longer than I expected however they did
indeed so once I lowered the price so as
you can see we are 18.9 male almost
nineteen already this episode I'm gonna
find some stuff to merge hopefully
before I go to bed I'm gonna start
editing in the previous episodes let's
do this think well I just came back from
work I think I made a really good really
smart I guess I would say decision I
decided that tonight rings don't really
buy and sell all that often because
they're just an uncharged form of the
ring of suffering so I figured I'd throw
in an offer for a woman like a lowball
offer for one of these I ended up
getting it for 17.3 and right now the
ring of suffering if we look it up real
quick and as you can see the ring of
suffering is not actively trade damn it
this doesn't prove my point
anyways I looked it up on OS buddy
anyways it sells for about eighteen
point five mil which means once I
enchant this we've made 1.2 mil
hopefully so now the moment of truth we
are going to try and enchant this is a
knight ring therefore making a ring of
suffering hopefully we can throw it in
here no kind of gives give us a price as
you can see I was pretty guy price
definitely right the total price I'm not
right at all well I was about to go to
bed and decided I'd throw this in for
eighteen point three mil and hopes that
maybe it would buy or I mean sell I
guess and it did indeed I I thought I
had it in there for a while eighteen
point five that I wasn't selling
nonetheless we still made a hundred or
one mil in 50k profit so I'm going to
try that again just because you know
natural thing to do found the margins on
these defens sets right now and it's
about it had ninety K or so however they
just instable ball to actually sold at
the same time so I'm a little curious as
far as to why that is however I'm just
gonna throw them back don't feel best
not even a minute later they both ended
up selling thought I had something to
worry about
apparently not it's been a little bit
and only one of these have bought so I'm
gonna list this back up and
I'm gonna change up the price of which
I'm selling a net well please didn't go
as planned needless to say as you can
see I sold them on for about 5 7 k
lesson I bought him for these two
I tried listing them up and they just
were not selling so I ended up just
dropping the price trying to start up a
couple merchants as you can see that
you're two of my trees have strings of
bought hundreds but actually been a long
time since I had the offer put in so I'm
just gonna throw them in for seven teen
85 probably and as far as the eternal
crystal goes I bought it for 4.3 mil
whatever I got what to try to sell it
and it wouldn't sell on for that so I'm
just gonna throw these in for ya four to
nine 5k okay so I am going to go play
some soccer but before we do before we
do before I do these treasonous rings
have not sold some when I drop the price
on them as I should - probably one seven
and seven okay we'll try that and as far
as the if I can't talk as far as these
eternal crystals go one of them have
sold however two of them have been
bought and not sold at all
so we are going to throw those up for
that price and hopefully this also
longer game back from soccer and as you
can see all of our trees those rings
have sold we'll collect that however
these have not sold so we're gonna have
to lower the prices a little bit don't
even want to know how much time later
but our eternal crystal has sold so once
we go like this damn it
are we really not at 20 mil yet are you
kidding me I thought we'd hit it before
I went to bed I ended up grabbing these
torsional seeds I never find my limit so
the price of them definitely went up so
we're gonna check out the price of them
right now and I'm gonna try to buy some
more as I'm about to back to bed I
literally just woke up for a second
alright as you can see 40k
9-3 go ahead and drive someone and 4252
so we're gonna sell all these on for
obviously 40k and then I'm through
alright just poke back up and as you can
to torso seats have sold and instead of
buying torso seeds because they didn't
have too big of a margin I bought
snapdragons seeds however they we're
over the met Bryce I'm a little nervous
as to whether or not these will now sell
so we're gonna buy one and I bought for
forty seven nine nine nine we go and
look over at the merch I bought them for
forty seven two five three which means
we're actually going to probably make
about 140km these so that's that's good
that's good yeah not even an hour later
so that all of these snapdragons seats
have sold so now we hit the 20 mil mark
twenty point one seven seven thank God
before that I just kept losing money on
so many things I was just afraid that we
weren't gonna hit at this episode
something started doing couple little
merges totally forgot about them but it
allows me to you know get some time and
buy out all of the ones I need to sew in
Sully's armadillo helmets on four one
one five eight because that's those
buddy price it's not what I initially
thought they'd sell for however 8.10 six
will be making 300k of all those sell
which would be nice and two of these
trees in the strings bought however the
rest are not so I'm assuming the
treasonous ring price also went out well
the armadillo helmets actually sold on
fairly quickly so as you can see we are
up - sorry I'm uploading the video right
now so it's gonna be a bit slow 17 male
on the dot so once we sell off these
trees in the strings we will have 20
point almost six mil which is insane
those are middle helmets are actually
something I used to merch a lot however
haven't done much of lately I might get
back into them there we go so both of
the treasonous rings would have sold
however I might ring did not buy about
that whenever I was at before I went to
work in hopes that somehow i'ma buy it
did not though so we'll find some
different items I don't know if it's
just me but these things always seem to
be really good merges I feel bad because
I constantly have them in the video but
look at this forty nine point two nine
nine and I bought them all for forty
eight point two so that's a 1k merch on
all of them well as you can see bought
and sold a ton of [__] tea
[__] off all right well as you can see
bought and sold a ton see it's not forty
nine point three let's go forty nine
point nine what did I buy this for forty
seven point six oh my god that's it's
over a 2k profit on each one of these so
didn't take much time at all and all of
these snapdragon seeds have sold so
there we go as I say twenty 1.3 mil
that's insane let's find some new items
well this is a typical merch I guess for
me but 87.6 K for you saplings I bought
these for 83k as you can see so about to
make four point five can each of these
once they sell I said when you do item
and sometimes I'll eyes let me check the
price snapdragons real quick
forty nine point nine K again look at
that two K birch on all of these like
how can you not want that and instantly
olive oil not really instantly it's been
probably five ten minutes but follow the
snapdragon seeds have sold so as you can
see five point eight eighty eight mil
for 118 of them however I bought 118 of
them for this price so you can check
this out look at that look at that
that's 5:17 so actually you can subtract
about 50 K so 233 profit though not bad
at all now everything's sold off I ever
catch that back and we are up to twenty
one point six mils so not too bad so I'm
gonna switch on over as you can see I've
been merging some deep boots I'm on my
other account right now dead bear mode
to start it up and I'm doing some
agility I'm just gonna grind it to 70
but look at this so I bought all of
these working with qo6 I was able to
sell a lot on for around 230 ish as you
can see however I'm still left with some
the rest sold for 215 and I'm going to
probably drop it to about 213 right now
and hopefully the rest will sell there
we go they've all sold so I'm gonna find
a different item I don't know what to
really to merge right now but we'll find
something found a little bit of a margin
on the gilded sets as you can see I
bought them for for 202 and I'll be able
to sell them on for 4 to 8 oh pretty
much so as expected the gilded
plate-like step hop why can't I say that
and the other three salt so hopefully
this will still have a decent price
ah what else would I be doing other than
[__] Snapdragon seed you guys can't
see how many I bought however I bought
77 so we're gonna go and throw these on
for let me see
49 100 is that is though we're looking
at right now
look at that barely any time at all 77
have sold and even more have been buying
so we're on uh we're on a pretty good
row here and apparently the Snapdragon
Tita I just bought all of these and I
just instace old Jesus what the [__]
Murch some more as you can see kind of
scroll through here if you guys if you
guys doubt me anyways I'm gonna collect
all of that so up to 17 pretty much 18
mill so what's this cops on out we will
have twenty three point two million
sighted thieves would be the items that
I was going to merge so treasonous rings
currently have like a 40k margin not too
shabby and eternal crystals apparently
have like a 200k margin we'll see I
don't believe it but I if they buy they
buy everything bought and sold so as you
can see I've sold on seven treasonous
rings this is finally sold added drop
the price a lot but let's collect it
real quick and twenty three point three
three eight male god damn so I did this
fun little merch as you can see arches
rings sold for 3.8 four mil I bought
them all for three point eight pretty
much how many 37k on each one so moving
a profit nothing too much though well
went to work ended up buying a 399
snapdragons he'd say buy a little bit
forward to four hours and so I went on I
mean to see what the price was right now
they are selling for let me check it out
real quick forty nine three nine eight
so I'm gonna throw these in real quick
forty nine three nine eight as you can
see we will then be selling these for
19.7 mil and considering we've bought
them for nineteen point two eight three
I would I'd say that's pretty good merch
of that as good as I wanted it to be but
it's not terrible alright so all the
Snapdragon teams have sold as you can
see the 399 are gone out of my inventory
anymore so 19.7 mil from
19-point 3-minute good 400 K um
hopefully these merchants we're good
enough for you guys for about 2 24 mm
but I think I want to end off the video
hopefully you guys enjoy it if you guys
did feel free to leave a like if you
guys have any ways of improving the
series leave it a comment down below and
if you want to see more in the future
leave a subscription it helps me out
immensely shows me it shows me a little
bit of support and I love it
nonetheless we're gonna end off the
video here hope you guys have a
wonderful day and fees